i am helena i'm 23 years old
[Music]
when i was about 15 i started using
tumblr
i
had an eating disorder since i was
pretty young
there's a lot of messages that said
if you feel bad about your body that
means you're trans
i was just going through this period of
like
i don't like how i'm treated as a cis
person i don't want to be cis because
cis means you're uncool and you're
privileged and you're an oppressor and
you're bad i don't want to be that
in that way i was really incentivized to
try to figure out a way
to make
my voice heard
in these communities and obviously i
can't change my race i can't really
change my sexuality
so the only thing left was to start
playing around with the gender stuff
so i decided to call myself a demi girl
which is one of the 40 million genders
and that basically means that i'm mostly
a girl but i'm a little bit not a girl
which is just like what does that even
mean and then after that i went to demi
boy and then after that i went to gender
gender fluid
and after that i eventually went to
trans boy but all this took like two or
three years of just
going through this repetitive cycle of
changing this identity and changing it
again and it was just never enough
[Music]
there was a lot of hopelessness for a
long time a lot of regret
the feeling of regret was intense
[Music]
ah
it's a moving interview and there's a
lot more of it in the episode helena
joins us on set now thanks so much for
coming on there's something so sad about
that first of all thank you for speaking
up because your voice does matter i
think in this conversation
but
you felt what every young woman i've
ever met
felt at a certain age which is
uncomfortable with yourself and it feels
like you were exploited at that moment
of weakness yeah absolutely i mean as
you said it's completely normal for not
only young girls but often young boys
too to feel uncomfortable with
themselves and comfortable with their
body
but we have this ideology that is
especially prevalent online that says
that if you have those feelings that
means you're trans i mean there are
literally people who say if you don't
even like your voice on a recording
that's a sign of gender dysphoria and
you need to go see a medical
professional because you're trans
talk about taking advantage of people so
how do you and this is all explained in
greater depth in the documentary but how
do you feel now at 23 looking back on
what happened i
feel
honestly grateful for the experience
because it's taught me a lot about the
world and about myself but i really feel
afraid for these other young girls like
myself who they might not be
you know i consider myself lucky that i
was able to get out of it unscarred
really medically but there's so many
young people who can't say the same
and psychologically as well i mean it's
just devastating to especially from a
young age be lied to by adults at school
and by medical professionals and told
that your body is wrong you need to
change it you need to get hormones you
need to get surgeries that's devastating
for a young person so i'm just really
concerned for younger girls and boys
like i once was being led down this path
um and and being hurt by it it's a
failure of male leadersh of adult
leadership and it does seem like some of
the steps are medically irreversible
absolutely i mean they there's all sorts
of you know the the white house actually
just put out a chart yesterday that says
that some of these steps are reversible
or partially reversible but that's such
an oversimplification of the truth i
mean when you go on a cross-sex hormone
like that's going to give you not just
physical changes but psychological
experiences that you can't just act like
they never happened you can't just take
it back and especially with surgeries
you know a
a breast implant after a mastectomy is
not the same thing as never having your
breasts taken off in the first place so
there's a lot of young women who are
going through that who had a double
mastectomy at 16 17 18 years old or
even younger that happens
who you know there's nothing you can
really do to
put that that feeling of of
oneness and safety in your body back
oh oh it's just it's heartbreaking i
hope people are hearing you with open
minds
with tolerance are they
um there's a lot of people out there
especially parents who are really
thankful for what i'm saying because
they see that their young girl or their
young boy is going through this and the
school is telling them you need to
affirm them they're trans you need to
transition them all their doctors are
telling them you need to transition them
and these parents they know
that their child should not be having
these cosmetic procedures so there's a
lot of parents who are really thankful
there are other young people who are
really thankful that i'm saying what i'm
saying but obviously you know you have
the trans activists and the trans
community that exhibits some very uh
unhealthy kind of cult-like dynamics who
are really upset about this man you are
so articulate and thoughtful at 23. it's
just it's remarkable thank you people
who have suffered like you have
sometimes get deeper yeah you learn a
lot like i said i learned a lot too
thank you thank you for talking to us
thank you
you're going to hear her full story and
others of people like her who've been
through this on fox nation in early may
it's one of a bunch of episodes we've
been working on stay with us for more
clips from season two of tucker carlson
original spirit
subscribe to the fox news youtube
channel to catch our nightly opens
stories that are changing the world and
changing your life from tucker carlson
tonight